se nos pide determinar la amplitud y el
periodo de la función ya igual a menos
un medio coseno de 3x y lo primero que
debemos preguntarnos es que es a qué se
refieren con la palabra amplitud a bueno
la amplitud de una función periódica es
simplemente la mitad de la diferencia
entre el valor máximo y el valor mínimo
que toma así que si yo dibujar una
función periódica y oscilan la dibujo
entonces la función periódica que voy a
dibujar oscila de esta manera
bueno sube y baja su viraje entre dos
valores así que este entre este valor y
este otro valor
tomás la diferencia entre los dos
valores y la mitad de eso es la amplitud
otra manera de pensar en esto en la
amplitud es cuánto o qué cantidad subió
desde su posición media y bueno por acá
tenemos la función igual a menos un
medio coseno de 3x entonces cuál será la
amplitud de esto la manera sencilla de
pensar en esto es bueno nos enfocamos en
el número que multiplica el valor coseno
y podrías hacer lo mismo si fuera una
función si fuera la función seno tenemos
aquí menos un medio multiplicándolo
entonces la amplitud en esta situación
es será el valor absoluto de menos un
medio amplitud es el valor absoluto de
este número menos un medio y lo cual es
igual a un medio baja entonces tal vez
tú digas bueno y porque no me importa el
signo porque debo yo tomar el valor
absoluto de esto si observas el signo
negativo simplemente voltea la función
sobre y debajo del eje de las equis
lo que oscila sobre el valor máximo y el
valor mínimo y la otra cosa es bueno
porque tomamos solo el valor absoluto de
esta cosa para darnos cuenta de por qué
solo debes recordar que una función
coseno una función seno oscila entre los
valores de uno y menos uno cierto
entonces el menos un medio simplemente
está multiplicando al uno positivo o al
menos uno normalmente la amplitud si no
tuviéramos el coeficiente aquí si el
coeficiente fuera a uno positivo uno
negativo la amplitud simplemente sería
uno pero ahora no estás multiplicando
por este número por lo tanto la amplitud
es un medio ahora lo que sigue es pensar
pensar hay que pensar en el periodo que
es el periodo bueno lo primero que te
quiero preguntar es que hace el periodo
de una función periódica a qué se
refieren con la palabra periodo en una
función periódica lo que haré aquí
primero primero que todo es dibujar unos
ejes en esta gráfica digamos qué
que esto de aquí es el eje de las íes
y acá tenemos el eje de las equis
entonces el periodo de una función
periódica es la longitud del intervalo
más pequeño que contiene exactamente una
copia de un patrón que se repite de esta
función periódica entonces a qué se
refieren que que se repite aquí así que
bueno vamos aquí a bajar bajamos luego
subimos después volvemos a bajar y
después volvemos a subir en este caso la
longitud del intervalo más corto que
contiene exactamente una copia del
patrón que se repite y bueno este puede
ser un patrón que buscamos puede ser el
patrón que buscamos uno de los pedazos
más pequeños del patrón por lo tanto la
longitud entre este punto y este punto
será será una es un periodo de aquí aquí
es un periodo y este no es el único
patrón que puedes elegir iniciando
puedes iniciar aquí luego puedes subir
después bajar puedes decir que esa
longitud es la más corta luego puedes
ver que si vas en la dirección negativa
repetición de ese patrón está también
ahí pero bueno de cualquier manera tú
obtendrás la misma magnitud la misma
distancia para volver a repetir ese
patrón cierto entonces dado eso cuál es
el periodo de esta función cuál es el
periodo de esta función bueno para
averiguar el periodo simplemente tomamos
2 spears y lo dividimos por el valor
absoluto del coeficiente entonces lo
dividimos entre el valor absoluto de 3
lo cual es simplemente 3 entonces entre
ver absoluto de 3 esto nos dan obtenemos
2 pi sobre 3 y ahora am por qué funciona
esto si tú piensas en una función coseno
tradicional si tomamos coseno de x la
función tradicional de coseno o una
función seno tradicional tiene un
periodo de 200 entonces si yo dibujo un
círculo unitario se inició inicio en 02
pirra dianas después dos pilares
recorridos te lleva al punto de partida
y también por ejemplo si tú vas en la
dirección negativa
negativa de bueno -2 y regreso al punto
de partida para cualquier ángulo aquí si
recorres dos pirra dianas regresas a ese
ángulo así que bueno si recorres menos
dos radiales regresas y por lo tanto el
periodo para esas funciones es de 2 spin
y la razón por la que esto tiene sentido
es porque este coeficiente hace que
llegues a 2 pide una manera más rápida
este coeficiente así que llegues más
rápido por lo tanto tu periodo será un
número más pequeño llegarás a dos y tres
veces más rápido y tal vez pienses bueno
y por qué porque tomo el valor absoluto
si esto fuera un valor negativo te
llevaría te llevaría a menos dos primas
rápido pero de cualquier manera estarías
completando un ciclo y ya con esta
información hay que visualizar voy a
dibujar aquí esta función menos un medio
coste no de 3x dibujo mis ejes el mejor
intento
y bueno este es mi eje de leyes y éste
es mi eje de las x ajá entonces bueno
ahí está y x luego vamos aquí aquí
tenemos el punto cero aquí tenemos el
punto cero ahí está x igual a cero y acá
está un medio como tú puedes ver aquí
voy a trazar esta línea punteada
como puedes ver aquí no vamos a
trasladar la función no tiene una
constante sumándose fuera de la función
coseno así que no se traslada pero
tenemos aquí un medio positivo y acá
abajo tenemos tenemos menos un medio
bajar dibujo estas líneas punteadas para
que para que me sea más sencillo trazar
la gráfica y ahora qué pasa cuando
cuando esto es cero coseno de cero es
uno pero lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicarlo por el menos un medio
entonces aquí inicia inicia en este
punto luego
va hacia arriba y solo puedes ir hacia
arriba porque está acotado luego
regresaría entonces va a subir
otras o lo mejor posible baja
entonces después se topa y baja
nuevamente baja luego llega al valor
mínimo y la pregunta es cuál es esta
distancia cuál es esta distancia la
recorrida cuánto mide esta longitud
bueno sabemos cuánto va a ser su periodo
es de 2 piso sobre 3 entonces llegará a
este punto tres veces más rápido que la
función coseno tradicional así que esto
va a ser este número aquí este punto de
dos piso bre tres y si seguimos si
recorremos otros dos pisos de tres
llegarás al mismo punto en este caso
habrá llegado a cuatro pisos sobre tres
entonces cuatro piso sobre tres y habrás
recorrido otro ciclo entonces esa
longitud también es un periodo ahora
puedes hacer lo mismo lo mismo para los
valores negativos entonces este punto de
aquí es menos dos piso sobre tres y para
visualizar la amplitud hay dos maneras
de pensar en esto la diferencia entre el
punto máximo y el punto mínimo es de un
medio
podrías decir que va un medio en
magnitud está oscilando en un medio
desde su punto medio ya sea que va en
dirección positiva o en dirección
negativa y bueno espero te haya servido
esto nos vemos pronto
bye